what if Luffy was never born in one
piece what would have happened to all of
the straw hats and who would have become
pirate king in his steps accidentally
spent an entire day that I was supposed
to be working playing through all the
possible scenarios and discovered one
timeline that seemed the most likely to
me and the results were so fascinating
and tragic that I thought hey why not
turn this into a video everything I'll
discuss will be based on the manga and I
swear you will not be able to guess who
actually will be crowned pirate king in
Louis stat in the ends so let's start
with Luffy's childhood years if Dragon
never got to find Luffy's mysterious
mother and make the future pirate king
quite a few things changed in the years
before the main storyline begins but not
quite as much as you might maybe think
for example GARP will still be on Don
Island looking after Roger's son Ace Ace
will still meet Sabo as he did without
Luffy anyways and both of them will
train together fight together and share
sake cups to become brothers trying to
sail away Sabo ship still gets sung by
the celestial dragons and and he is once
again rescued and taken in by Dragon you
know maybe in this timeline he finally
realized that having a kid that you
never get to see is not a great idea now
the biggest change in this version of
the story of course are the events that
happen in chapter one Shanks still
arrives in fuchsia Village but never
gets to meet Luffy Who as a result
doesn't eat the gumugumu slash nikonika
fruit and therefore never becomes Joy
boy and so here we have to make our
first speculation and decision that's
gonna have a major impact on how this
all plays out what would happen with
this legendary fruit instead and at this
point I'm gonna make an assumption that
I believe is very likely to be true but
not yet 100 confirmed in the story if
you've seen any of my other content you
will probably know that I firmly believe
that originally Shanks was planning to
give the Nika fruit to none other than
Ace before Luffy then simply gobbled it
down and made himself the new chosen one
let me explain Shanks clearly knew about
the importance of the Nika fruit the
Government tried to get their hands on
it for centuries and once they finally
did Shanks was there to take it away
from them we also know that Roger found
out about joyboy and his prophesized
return on love tale so he made sure to
create the great pirate earandra as many
people as possible to fight the right
person that would mean joyber's return
we know that he placed his former
crewmate crocus at the entrance of the
grand line to wait for the right person
to arrive I mean crocus literally says
you might be the one that we've been
waiting for Roger when he meets Luffy
for the first time and his right-hand
man Rayleigh is stationed at sabodi
archipelago the choke point that you
have to pass in order to reach the new
world Rayleigh knew about Luffy from
Shanks and spent two entire years
training Luffy to prepare him for the
second half of his journey and when
Luffy finally awakens his devil fruit
zunisha takes his heartbeat as the sign
of joyboy's return so I think it's very
likely that shanks's task as the crew
member that Raja entrusted his Straw Hat
to was to find the right person to eat
this fruit and guide his way to becoming
Pirates King now as we know this is now
Luffy but he ate the fruit by accident
and we also know that Roger was eager to
have a son before he died which is Ace a
guaranteed member of the d-clan just
like Luffy so I think that sheng's went
to Don Island not on a fluke but to give
this legendary fruit to Ace the son of
his former captain and make him the next
Joy boy and so if Luffy was never born I
believe that exactly this would most
likely have happened Shanks finds Ace
and gives him the Nikka fruit he might
even sacrifice his arm once again to
make sure that Ace would try to become a
great pirate as well after that however
I think that things would stay actually
quite similar Shanks make sure to watch
over Ace from afar but lets him kind of
do his own thing as a result Ace becomes
a pirate becomes captain of the space
pirates gets defeated by Whitebeard and
once again joins whitebeard's crew very
much to the displeasure of shang's
raelian Co because Whitebeard doesn't
have any interest in going to love tail
but also is 2 powerful to be convinced
otherwise although not for a lack of
trying here so as a result Ace becomes a
strong pirate and command on the
Whitebeard only that this time he has
rubber Powers instead of fire powers but
Ace is pretty smart as we know and he
figures out how to use his fruit
effectively just like Luffy did which
now finally brings us to the current
timeline and the straw hats if Luffy was
never born and never set out to see to
gather his crew what would have happened
to each of them without him things get
quite dark so we start these blue Saga
by going to alvida ship where Luffy pops
out of a barrel at the beginning of the
storyline to save Kobe but this time
around however there is nothing in this
Barrel as a result Kobe will for the
rest of his life be forced to work the
deck on the pirate ship he will never be
inspired to follow his impossible
looking dream of becoming a Marine
Admiral and as a direct result of this
neither he nor Luffy make it to Morgan's
Marine base where Zorro is being starved
death by helmeppo without Luffy coming
to save him Zoro at some point realizes
that helmeppo never meant to stand by
his word to release him after 30 days
without food instead Zoro who at this
point is too weak to free himself simply
starves to death in a horrifying and
tragic manner a quite pitiful end for
the future's strongest swordsman in the
world mihawk never even learns his name
a little later starting from Orange Town
buggy manages to reach the grand line
but is soon captured by the Marines
anyways Nami has barely managed to
outwit buggy and Escape him even without
Luffy's help at this point answer a
village kudo's three-year plans who
plunder the island is finally complete
despite usob's warning of pirates no one
in the village believes him at first
usop wants to be brave and fight but is
paralyzed by fear and he runs away and
ultimately he and all the other
villagers are just slaughtered by Kudos
men while his dad is having a party with
zhangs somewhere in the new world I
guess and so in this scenario usop will
never become a brave Warrior of the sea
the only way to save us up here is by
subscribing right now at the baratier
things go A bit differently though while
Luffy isn't there to save the baratia
from Donkey when you think about it
Creek only survives mihawk chasing after
him because mihawk becomes more
interested in Zorro and his Challenge
and so with Zorro still slowly wasting
away in the afternoon son of Morgan's
base mihawk simply finishes what he came
here for all the way from the grand line
sink the rest of dawn Creek's ship so
instead of the Marathi is sinking I
think mihawk would eat Creek for lunch
and then have a nice dinner with some
good wine at the baratier as a result
Sanji keeps working there happily after
as a cook for two more years until a
Mafia Boss shows up at the restaurant he
tells Sanji that he's going to be
married unless he wants all of the cooks
on the ship to die and so Sanji complies
and is taken to whole cake Islands here
he is humiliated by his family before
big mom's crew then murders the entire
Vin smoke family at the wedding and
takes over German's technology meanwhile
nami's Village is never freed from
arlang's rule his men come to confiscate
all the money that she saved up so far
and despite her despair here she can't
let her people down either so she keeps
keeps drawing more and more maps for our
long locked in her tiny room inside his
castle now at this point in the main
storyline Luffy and his crew would enter
the grand line and are starting to make
a name for themselves as rookies without
Luffy however crocus has met Ace but
wasn't of any real help as he was with
Whitebeard laboon keeps smashing his
head against the red line until he
finally succumbs to his injuries and
Rook will never be able to keep his
promise with the whale they will never
meet again on drum Island Chopper lives
his life with kureha scared and unsure
about where he belongs in this world as
a monster in an outcast at some point
waffle returns to the country and he
then kicks him and Korea out of the
castle and both of them have to live
under his tyranny Ace still comes to
drum however looking for Blackbeard who
has taken the yummy Yami Nomi and
betrayed the crew in this timeline as
well this had nothing to do with Luffy
after all in the meantime crocodile is
finally able to overthrow Alabaster
without any major issues really he kills
the king and VV and finds the secret
chamber under the capital here either
Robin refuses to tell him anything about
pluton and is killed by crocodile or she
does tell him the truth that pluton
isn't here but is located under the
country of wano in the new world under
the control of kaido and so crocodile
manages to build his power from here
much much faster than if he had been
caught and brought simple down and he
starts preparing a plan to take on kaido
Robin meanwhile goes her own separate
path but is sooner or later captured by
the Agents of cp9 or cp0 and brought to
imple down as well the last scholar of
O'Hara captured she will never find out
that Saul is still alive or that the
library of O'Hara has actually been
saved instead she fully vanishes into
the darkness of her heart and the depths
of the level 6 of imple down now Sky Pia
again is very interesting actually
because without Luffy's interference
anole is a God for a little while longer
before them just making his way to the
Moon anyways this time he's accompanied
by his men also Bellamy gets to keep his
teeth this time around on water 7
Frankie simply living his delinquent
life as the head of the frankly family
at some point Luchi and the other cp9
agents find out that he had the plans
for the pluton I think it's fair to
assume that even in this timeline
Frankie would heroically burn the plants
in front of Lucci's eyes but is executed
by the Furious agent who has at this
point turned into a giant leopard
meanwhile Shanks is once again meeting
with Whitebeard he's here to talk about
Blackbeard and urges new gates to call
Ace back he is way too important to die
in the Florian triangle Brook spends the
next year alone in the dark without his
Shadow Warrior meanwhile grows his
zombie army and finds a suitable Shadow
for oars instead of Luffy he then takes
Thriller bark to the new world and
decides to attack wano once again
convinced that this time he can win
however even with ors's reanimated
corpse he can stand up to the might of
the Beast Pirates while he's actually
able to enter the country and and lay
Siege to the flower Capital once Orochi
calls for help kaido and the All-Stars
swoop in and ultimately defeat his army
in less than 10 minutes as a result of
this Brook's Shadow is released and he
does go on to become a rock star just as
he did during the time skip in the main
storyline and at the same time onimaru
is able to bury ryuma's corpse that has
been left behind by Modia back at his
grave and lies shoe sui on top of it
after Thriller bark the tragedy on Saba
ODI archipelago never happens a bunch of
rookies known as the first generation
meet here and then just move on to the
new worlds Kami isn't safe by Rayleigh
and is sold to Carlos because Rayleigh
is actually off seeing Whitebeard to
urge him that Ace has the next Joy boy
has to become pirate king meanwhile wipe
it reveals to Rayleigh that he was
planning to make Ace his successor all
along that Roger had told him the truth
about the d-clan and his son and that he
simply had wanted to make sure that Ace
was ready but at this point it's too
late Ace confronts Blackbeard as in the
main storyline and is captured and taken
to imple down jimbei and ivankov never
escape to prison until much much later
when Dragon actually orders morally to
get them out and so jimbei actually
becomes a revolutionary and so I would
argue that even without Luffy the war at
Marine for it still happens this time
Blackbeard tries to sneak into imple
down to get the level 6 prisoners for
his crew but without Luffy's Uprising
and without shirio being released to
stop him Magellan wipes out the entire
Blackbeard crew and this time there is
no antidot Blackbeard had made one
gamble too much and lost to fate and
therefore the most likely candidate for
pirate king has died without anyone even
realizing it meanwhile at Marine Forge
the war is about to begin but this time
things are a little bit different
Rayleigh and most of the remaining Roger
Pirates have come to fight side by side
with Whitebeard to free joy boy the one
hope to act actually change the world
that they have been working towards so
carefully for over 20 years Shanks and
his crew also joined the war right from
the start it's really all or nothing
here and so at first the two yongo Crews
seem to have the upper hand easily
breaching the first few lines of
defenses here mihawk has completely
refused to even come and fight against
his former friend and resign from the
warlord system however suddenly the sky
blackens as a giant Azure Dragon appears
over the Navy headquarters and a fleet
of ships appears on the horizon because
Shanks never went to stop him kaido
managed to join the war and has decided
to make it the biggest battle the world
has ever seen as we know he wants to
draw out joyboy here and now we have
three parties fighting the war at the
same time as a result sengoku orders Ace
to be executed right now during the
chaos chinx uses his hockey to
temporarily knock out almost every
single person on the battlefield except
the other two yonko Rayleigh the Admiral
sengoku garib and a few other selected
people before Shanks can do anything
though kaido stands in his way and asks
Shanks if he could be Joy boy to which
shangs yells at him that it's Ace not
him now kaido is really shocked by this
but it is too late at this point Akainu
has returned to the Executioner platform
and Ace dies the same way he did last
time this time not even able to give his
life for his little brother and as a
result the entire Battlefield shocked
falls into an eerie silence but then
something strange happens suddenly Ace
begins to melt as a Drum Slowly starts
to beat in the background Ace just like
Luffy has died and thus awakened his
legendary devil fruit Joy boy has
returns with an awakened Ace who already
is quite a lot older and stronger than
Luffy was at this point the tight of the
battle quickly turns even kaido has
decided to now join their side at least
for now because he has been waiting for
joyboy's return his entire life however
as the Marines and the shichibukai are
about to be completely annihilated a
dark shadow falls on the island once
again there is something huge above the
clouds then a bright light just like the
sun and marineford Islands never existed
IMO and the gorosei have decided to
sacrifice their strongest fighters in
order to take out three yankos and
joyboy in one foul swoop okay so in the
aftermath of this immense War the last
standing yonko is now big mom who
collects shanks's and kaido's Road
pornoglyphs and takes over wano and Elba
with Orochi by her side two years later
when momonosuke conjuro and kinemon
appear from the past she learns the
location of zou from conjuro and takes
the last poniglyph from there as well
then using pudding's abilities she is
able to decipher the hidden location of
Love tail and is crowned queen of the
Pirates oh yeah you wouldn't guess it
however as she reads joyboy's words on
love tale she realizes that she can
can't change the world without the Nika
fruits and when you really think about
it it's kind of crazy how important
juano is even in a world without Luffy I
mean there are just so many things that
we just learned in this one Arc if you
want a one hour plus breakdown of all of
mono and why it was so controversially
received you can watch that right here
right now if you want